[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette édition
d' espace autochtones en direct un
plateau bien chargé aujourd'hui on va
aborder un enjeu qui est crucial en ce
moment qui évidemment fait l'actualité
partout à travers le pays où elle
souhaitait mais avant 14 février oui
saint valentin mais aussi une journée
importante pour les femmes autochtones
disparues et assassinées
il ya des marches qui ont lieu
aujourd'hui alors entre autres je vais
tout de suite vous présentez nous
inviter plus on va pouvoir en parler
donc il avait le picard bonjour isabelle
marlene mail elle est de la nation oued
souhaitons bonjour merci d'être là
aujourd'hui kwanten condos rappeur
micmacs de gace k b blague
bonjour quindlen c'est vrai bien oui et
puis mélissa melissa maulin dupuis une
militante aussi qui travaille à la
fondation david suzuki et puis n'est-ce
pas merci d'être là
alors avant de parler de watson parce
que c'est vraiment le sujet
d'aujourd'hui parlons des femmes
autochtones disparues et assassinées que
nous allons commémorer ce soir c'est une
journée qui est important c'est la
journée de la mort enfin andré comme on
a des enquêtes qui se sent qu'ils ont
été faites
faut quand même montré qu'ils encore une
problématique de femmes assassinées
d'hystérie faut pas qu'elle tombe dans
l'oubli on impose que la commission sont
des femmes à ces disparus a eu lieu donc
il va y avoir des marches des
manifestations qui vont se rajouter
aussi comment je crois dire dans l'idée
des watts ou est elle aussi parce que
c'était un moment très important quand
il ya eu l'arrestation des femmes
étaient en train de faire un champ pour
les femmes assassinées disparu quand
justement la grc a emporté ses femmes de
façon illégale que vous les avez sur le
territoire et ça s'était accompagnée de
chez et de fusils donc aujourd'hui ça
prend un double sens que de voir
véritablement comment l'état haut la
main sur les femmes et les risques
qu'elles vivent à tous les jours voilà
donc des marchés en aura partout à
travers le canada mais il y en a aussi à
montréal
elles ont lieu je pense au centre ville
de montréal à partir de 17h si je me
trompe et c'est pourquoi vous portez ce
petit carré rouge ah oui on s'attaque à
penser pour pas confondre avec le carré
rouge de 2012 c'est la robe des femmes
qu'on voit des robes c'est pour rappeler
qu'un corps des femmes qui disparaissent
et de plus en plus la campagne prend de
l'ampleur car aux états unis aussi on
voit la campagne des femmes assassinées
disparaît disparu à paraître dans les
médiums et je parle même pas du mexique
d'amérique du sud où c'est une
problématique existe depuis des
décennies aussi et dont elle cherche à
avoir de la tension
et puis quand nuit il a mis un quart est
d'une couleur un peu différente une
couleur orange brûlé
oui ça c'est un petit morceau de peau
d'orignal piscines camping qui se fait
pour amener la tension autour de la
violence contre les femmes qui les
enfants c'est vraiment comme mis en
place pour les hommes
oui c'est ça se fait qu'il ya des
événements qui qui sont autour de
journée très importante mais une autre
journée très importante
évidemment c'est ce conflit qui se
déroule autour de la nation watson et
voilà pourquoi on à marlene r
aujourd'hui parce que marlene vous êtes
de la nation watson oui depuis 2012 est
chef cuisinière voilà alors une belle
façon donc de découvrir les watts
m'étonne c'est aussi par la cuisine
c'est très bien que vous le fassiez ici
même en plus à montréal
là évidemment ce qui se passe sur le
territoire des webséries tonnes est
tellement important qu'il a pris de
l'ampleur partout à travers le pays
alors on peut rappeler évidemment il ya
une compagnie gazière constant gathering
qui veut faire passer son pipeline sur
le territoire traditionnel des oueds
slaten
évidemment il ya déjà des premières
nations watson qui sont d'accord avec le
passage de ce pipeline et il ya les
traditionalistes qui eux ne sont pas
d'accord et qu'on pourrait expliquer
isabelle exactement qui sont ces chefs
traditionnels mais enfin on parle de
chef héréditaire donc oui les gens les
connaissent moins on en a moins dans
l'est ce canadien quoique y en a quand
même quelques-uns
ce sont des chefs qui comme le nom le
dit finalement vont se transmettre le
pouvoir de génération en génération et
ce bien avant sa date de bien avant la
colonisation
donc il y en a un chez line gigault
entre autres il y en a chez les leaders
y en a chez les huit souhaitait et leur
pouvoir en fait bon avec la loi sur les
indiens évidemment tout ce système
traditionnel là qui existait chez les
oiseaux étaient nommés ailleurs partout
finalement chez les premières nations de
golf du canada va être renversé
complètement et on va mettre en place le
système de conseil de bande
un système qu'on dit démocratique mais
en tout cas faut voir jusqu'où et le
saut c'est une autre histoire mais qu'on
va élire donc des chefs à l'intérieur du
conseil de bas principalement dans la
nation est souhaité n les chefs de bande
s'occupe des affaires courantes les chef
héréditaire s'occupe des affaires du
territoire traditionnel maintenant ce
qui est bien intéressant est ce qu'on
oublie de mentionner c'est que d'autant
plus de rodez chef héréditaire ont été
confirmés par la cour suprême en 1997
donc à cette époque là il ya eu la
justice au déclaré que la nation n'avait
jamais cédé son territoire traditionnel
et du même coup reconnaissait le rôle
des chefs héréditaire donc sur ce
territoire donc c'est quand même pour y
est donc brièvement chef de bande pour
les affaires courantes et chefferies de
stars pour ce qui est des territoires
tradition voilà et donc ce sont eux qui
n'ont pas été approché en fait le
gouvernement ne s'est pas tourné vers
eux pour leur demander l'autorisation de
passer sur leur territoire avec le
pipeline mélissa mais je dirais que oui
sont tournés vers eux mais les ont pas
écoutés quand ils y ont dit un non très
attendu on les avait on les avait
consulté on reconsulter impôts de eur
venir des restes ont pu partiel par
exemple un nom les buy et d'utiliser
toutes les autres chefs qui sont des
chefs dans la réserve pour l'approbation
des oueds souhaitait parce qu'il ya
aussi une confusion énorme dans le droit
canadien chez les canadiens de faire la
différence entre les nations entre les
communautés
la meilleure manière que je peux essayer
de l'expliquer des fois c'est imaginer
si quelqu'un voudrait faire passer un
pipeline entre l'ontario et le
terre-neuve
oui et qu'on pense à travers le québec
va leur demander la permission oui mais
les autres provinces ont dit oui mais
c'est la même chose des chefs qui ont
dit oui n'avait pas la juridiction sur
le territoire et en plus ce qui est
clair c'est que vous avez pas la
juridiction sur la question qui est
entourée du territoire donc c'est
vraiment aller chercher comme on dit
excusez-moi l'expression mais d un
indien pour pouvoir faire passer des
droits et on a vu ça par le passé et
aujourd'hui des gens de plus en plus une
idée claire de ce que c'est être
autochtone être l'un des inscrits à être
un ennemi être un métis et on se rend
compte que le droit autochtone est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce qu'on
nous vend à la télé oui alors les enjeux
sont énormes parce qu'il ya des enjeux
politiques qu'il ya des enjeux
économiques on le voit bien sûr avec les
trains qui ne peuvent plus circuler à
travers le pays des enjeux sociaux
également marlene comment ça se passe
actuellement dans vos communautés en
colombie-britannique parce qu'il doit y
avoir il ya un conflit donc entre ses
chefs héréditaire et les conseils de
bande
comment ça se passe actuellement tout né
à zurich yassine est en tout cas de
bagdad
back to back communauté
[Musique]
avec une division de mandat oui oui si
je peux me permets marlene
elle évoque justement les festins hier
il ya eu le festin de la fumée il faut
pas oublier que la loi sur les indiens a
carrément interdit les festins et
personne ne voyait l'importance mais
c'est un c'est une instance politique
que le festin et comme elle disait les
chefs sont venus donner la nouvelle et
informer les gens de la communauté pour
avoir ensuite un sens du retour de la
communauté sont les enjeux un peu comme
ellen gabriel avait été mandaté par sa
communauté pour pouvoir parler au nom de
la communauté 15 était ok et comment
marier l'eau si c'était c'est que une
des politiques très importantes qu'on
voit présentement avec costaud garçons
c'est la politique de la division mettre
les chefs de bande contre les chefs
traditionnels ceux qui veulent les
pipelines contre ceux qui ne veulent pas
les pipelines et je pense que c'est une
des raisons pourquoi la mobilisation de
support aux autres souhaitaient n'a été
si grande
c'est que c'est un enjeu qui va se
refléter sur toutes les provinces
on a tous des projets qui sont
présentement mis de l'avant et dont on
bénéficie de la division des chefs et de
la communauté présentement je pense
juste au parc plein gnl sans vie au
québec donc c'est pas dur de comprendre
pourquoi voir l'arrestation de femmes
sur leur territoire pu avoir le choc
entre toutes les nations autochtones
parce que ça veut dire
même quand on a un droit reconnu même
qu'on ait des politiques qui existent
depuis des milliers d'années même encore
aujourd'hui justin trudeau pour
respecter le droit canadien est bien le
droit des femmes d'être sur leur
territoire millénaire le droit de faire
des festins tout ça c'est du droit
canadien et qui est plus ancien encore
que le canada et ça c'est un droit
canadien qui est reconnue en plus par
les taux canadiens qui s'écrit
à partir de 10 ans donc les femmes qu'on
veut montrer comme illégalement sur leur
territoire ont dû construire des
campements pour pouvoir montrer
visuellement que c'était chez eux mais
en tant que tel on dit des papes ne m'a
donc l'entièreté du territoire étaient
occupés mais comme on doit toujours
continuellement répondre aux demandes du
colonisateur ça doit d'avoir une
explication d'égaler les utilisent les
moyens qui sont présents et chanté dansé
sur leur territoire c'est une présence
physique continue qui demande évidemment
par la cour suprême
alors ce que marlene elle explique que
c'est la continuation
malgré l'interdiction pendant très
longtemps d'une politique canadienne qui
est établi et qui millénaire et que peu
de gens connaissent et que peu de gens
parce que justement la loi sur les
indiens servait à faire disparaître
droit là elles ont dû se cacher souvent
les nations pour faire leurs traditions
pour pouvoir continuer les chefs
d'actionnaires oui jusqu'à ce que cela
devienne plus illégal mais c'est grave
c'est justement à la résistance de ses
chefs le qui a encore des chefs
traditionnels qui ont encore ici un peu
partout mais ça a toujours dû être fait
dans l'ombre mais c'est toujours
continue par exemple c'est quelque chose
que personne
on dirait le monde sont confuses et si
c'est qui qui a la pouvoir le dessus
quand tu parles de la décision à dire le
moc à 97
mais ces décisions la cour suprême du
canada mais s'était terminée en cours
par les chefs militaires pas par les
chefs de conseils de bangui ces textes
est gagné par les chefs auraient dit r
ça fait que le gouvernement il sait très
bien ce qui est en charge leur temps à
gaza territoire là c'est un territoire
de 22 mille kilos mais qu'il aimait
caresser ça se fait qu ils savent très
bien pillay ont eu le pas la bonne
réponse qui voulaient tous des noms
ayant consulté avec les chefs
l'eau y ont été validés chef du conseil
de bande mais lyon pour fêter ça comme
il faut maintenant parce que je trouve
particulier c'est que en 2018 le
gouvernement de la colombie britannique
et le gouvernement fédéral ont dit oui
donc à ce projet de deux pipelines et
est donc et de yachts et donc ils ont
fait finalement de cette décision de la
cour suprême bloque du canada donc dans
leur propre droit de leur propre justice
ça fait pas de sens
ma vie égalité de m absolument il serait
fait se respecte même pas leur propre
droit alors qu'il a reçue en grays grc
il rentre le dandy la peau protégée une
injonction pour les compagnies c'est pas
de mon sens il ya eu une loi qui dise
que le territoire ni le gouvernance de
la territoire au chef qui te faire
respecter cette loi présentement c'est
les citoyens et je pense que si on voit
une différence en 2012 quand on sait on
est sortis dans les rues et aujourd'hui
en 2020 il ya une différence énorme et
c'est l'appui des citoyens qui se
rendent compte parce qu'ils sont
maintenant informés de plus en plus sur
les enjeux et les injustices vécues par
les communautés autochtones donc en
sortant dans les rues en appuyant ya des
syndicats d'enseignants il ya des
étudiants il ya des gens d'un peu
partout au canada qui disent respecter
les watts ou étonne et les voitures et
un enfant c'est l'image même de toutes
les communautés autochtones à travers le
canada
c'est fou le comment on va voir
justement cette division là être
utilisés contenu et malheureusement cela
permet aussi de faire une montée de
beaucoup de commentaires très racistes
sur les programmations qui se mobilisent
et se mobilise pas n'importe comment
n'importe où ils sont sur leur
territoire présentement les tracts de
chemin de fer qui ont été construits
sont sur des territoires autochtones et
ça c'est une manière de dire bien si
vous voulez pas qu'on bloque vos projets
arrêtez de les faire sur nos territoires
quand on vous dit de pas les femmes et
là vous verrez
différence mais je pense que aussi une
mais quelque chose de super important la
grc la grc la police qui a été créé au
canada pour gérer les indiens sur leurs
terres d'indiens et confidente arisée
les premières nations et les communautés
autochtones qui ont emporté les enfants
dans les pensionnats
c'est une relation extrêmement compliqué
quand on nous les envoient encore une
fois sur des territoires touchés à des
femmes autochtones sont dans leur droit
on peut comprendre qu'on n'a aucune
aucune idée comment est-ce que l'état la
police et l'industrie ont pas tous la
main dans le sac d'argent puisque même
si on parle de la consultation qu'ils
ont fait avec les conseils de bande
les vins conseil de ben oui ce n'était
pas une rencontre plaisante
c'était comme s'il y avait le couteau
aux morts ils ont dit tu things un
théâtre louis ou tard rien et on va
faire pareil
alors ce que vous dites finalement c'est
qu'on a poussé les conseils de bande en
ait pas de choix et dans les ententes
il ya des conditions comme quoi ils vont
de façon raisonnable empêcher les gens
de la communauté de manifester de faire
des campagnes en ligne
donc même ils vont donner la
responsabilité aux chefs de gérer leurs
populations il faut pas oublier que les
réserves ce sont des administrations
dans son lit cher doivent gérer de la
pauvreté manufacturés par l'état avec un
sous financement et ça c'est merveilleux
parce que les chefs traditionnels que
d'autres ne sont pas responsables de
cette administration là peuvent gérer un
territoire
mais là les chefs on leur dit de faire
de l'argent mais il faut que tu fonction
de la taille de ton voisin et ce qui
m'énerve le plus qui me fait le plus
peur moi c'est que ces projets qui s'en
viennent au québec et bien beaucoup de
nos chefs de bande son aussi les chefs
traditionnels et beaucoup de nos chefs
doivent gérer les 2 en même temps et
souvent qu'est ce que tu vas choisir la
fatigue d'avoir sous financé tête à
communauté ou à accepter des projets
qu'on te dit inévitable parce que c'est
ce qui arrive qu'on nous rende dans les
cours suprêmes qu'on nous garde dans des
procès qui interminables ont fait les
projets ont détruit territoire et après
on dit que vous aviez raison c'est vos
territoires et après ça donne des
compensations donc c'est la même chose
que si on avait dit oui
début et vous pouvez imaginer comment on
voit que la lutte est perdue d'avancé
pour certains chefs et comment on essaye
quand même de se faire entendre quand de
faire de façon pacifique parce que on
n'est pas allé tourner la garnotte chez
le voisin là on s'est assis sur nos
terres on dit vous passerez plus et ça a
bloqué le canada au complet samedi
l'emploi de nos territoires louis là
vous parliez tout à l'heure des des gens
qui sont derrière vous et aussi beaucoup
de gens qui sont contre vous et on le
voyait dans un sondage qui est sorti ce
matin sondage de l'institut angus reid
39% des répondants appuient les
manifestations et les manifestants
solidaires au chef héréditaire witz owe
étonne même si 51% d'entre eux affirment
être en accord avec la construction du
gaz costaud gaz ling 39% des répondants
c'est pas la majorité on est loin de la
majorité il faut comprendre aussi chat
soit le pourcentage ou ne rien dire oui
si si les chefs dit non c'est non
c'est leur territoire ça dérange pas tu
peux faire des votes comme tu veux
-selon territoire qui s'y dit non c'est
non
le consulter cette consultation s'est
mis notre enseignement non mais mais le
danger aussi cette semaine
tout le reste la population canadienne à
dos tous ceux qui sont contre les
manifestations de la part des chefs en
fait d'aider de tous ces gens qui se
retrouvent là sur les barrages on
utilise beaucoup le fait économique pour
rien sa in apprécié par la population
juste vous il ya 180 3 assez justes même
pas 200 ans
il y avait une économie qu'on a essayé
d'abolir un peu partout au canada puis
aux états unis qui étaient contre mais
l'économie va s'effondrer et s'appelle
esclavage et la 11ème et les tanneries
va s'effondrer non l'économie assez
modifiée à se transformer parce que
c'était une économie et juste
présentement ça c'est une économie est
juste ça détruit des territoires ça le
corridor de ressources naturelles
diminue pour les ouates souhaitait à
chaque jour à chaque fois qu'il ya un
projet comme ceux qui pensent et c'est
pas le seul projet c'est plusieurs
auraient injecté aux émules donc
aujourd'hui les caribous les
les bisons toutes les animaux qui se
mange encore dans les communautés sont
malades sont au disparaissent l'eau et
puis buvable les poissons disparaissent
est présentement la capacité même de
vivre sur un territoire qui avant était
d'une richesse incroyable parce qu'il
faut pas oublier qu'en colombie
britannique
ce sont des chasseurs et des qu'ailleurs
mais l'environnement est tellement riche
de ressources naturelles qu'il pouvait
être sédentaires un certain point et
l'oeuvre tranquillement puisque j'en
pense et on peut plus chasser on peut
plus manger on peut plus trouver sur le
territoire ce qu'on trouvait
naturellement en regardant d'ordre c'est
sûr que c'est une économie est juste et
les premiers touchés les canari dans la
mine c'est toujours les communautés
autochtones parce qu'on a misé sur le
territoire mais oui tu souhaites en sont
carrément sur le territoire pas depuis
10 ans comme c'est dit parce qu'il ya un
campement où ils ont mené depuis des
plus de 10 la wii
marlene parlez nous de votre territoire
décrivez-nous le territoire d'où vous
venez de museler un sac cabas trois
saumons souligne last year the west wing
3h10 les guest panaf foot fric of the
white house d'anciens camarades
10h05 inspection le match om nice
personnes avaient tous les yeux sont
tournés sur le canada actuel de partout
à travers le monde des lettres notre
interprète aujourd'hui
elissa ses cendres ont commencé on va
essayer de résumer tout ce que nous a
dit mme arlene on commence évidemment
par parler d'environnement et de comment
la nature est touchée par le passage de
ce pipeline je sais tout traduire de
façon comment ça se passe alors à dire
que l'autre fait 3 millions de saumons
l'année dernière joue les magasins
monceau kérosène ce qui passait sur le
territoire et l'année dernière il ya non
seulement dix mille qui ont passé
faisait qu'elle va ce qu'il appelle le
fait chevaux de la nourriture qui
décriaient du poisson il va nourrir
toute une famille pendant l'hiver et
l'année dernière
cette année il ya seulement deux
poissons par famille oui
donc c'est pour dire je pense qu'il ya
aussi des des manipulations de
heureusement du parcours toute façon les
têtes des fermes et des fois des chemins
de ses passagers sommes en ce moment
pour faciliter les rapports et des
alentours mais aussi des mousses décarie
des minuteries nom et qui vont avoir la
confusion par rapport à leur parcours
naturel parce que justement les travaux
de pipelines et on voit souvent comment
les animaux vont changer leur manière de
migrer à cause des travaux des humains
on sait que les cervidés sont certains
des plus sensible par rapport à la
présence humaine
mais mardi elle évoquait aussi qu'elle
avait quelque chose qui était très très
pratique pour elle c'est que beaucoup de
gens la réconciliation est morte et a
dit moi je pense pas il faut pas qu'on
la laisse se faire mais il faut qu'on la
garde ouverte et qu'on dit fermer le
canada c'est problématique pour elle
parce que ça lui fait très peur et je
pense que je comprends ou la pendule
apparent vient parce que la réalisation
peut être très difficile sur les
communautés
je pense que le monde veulent c'est
d'être entendu et de voir justement
cette réconciliation le pour mourir d'un
coup puis dire qu'on ne finit une
nouvelle relation
d'ailleurs moi j'utilise pas la
réconciliation est morte la
réconciliation est morte vive la
réconciliation en voulons dire on va
avancer dans une nouvelle forme de
réconciliation qui ne sera pas facile
mais qui vont être inscrits sur quelque
chose de vrai c'est à dire une
discussion ça peut pas uniquement des
services avait pas uniquement de tenir
la main ça doit être une discussion
oui c'est pour moi aussi c'est aller de
l'avant parce que comme tu dis marne et
on vit tous ensemble
on peut plus on peut pas te déchirer
légende même si nous voyons des gens
ignoré deux fois il y aurait une autre
voisin d'ailleurs je pense que si une
chose qui était très claire par les
chefs traditionnels si je me trompe pas
c'est qu'ils ont fait pas ça juste pour
les watts ou et l on fait ça pour tout
le monde et ça c'est un message très
clair il ya des chefs traditionnels
ce ne sont pas uniquement pour nous
c'est pour l'avenir de tout le monde ça
c'est vrai j'ai entendu d'autres chefs
ici même ici au québec aussi dire la
même chose là y compris et tout le monde
les familles sont entremêlées maintenant
nous nos vies sont entremêlés oui mais
on peut plus aller de l'avant comme son
peuple avec une relation qui est biaisé
et malheureusement que j'écoutais le 39
% d'approbation et je me suis dit mais
s'arrêter combi ya quinze ans c'est
combien que ça aurait été sympa ça
change à tous les jours mais c'est parce
qu'on fait le travail que d'ici et je
pense que c'est une lutte qui est
exemplaire dans l'histoire du canada
c'est la déprogrammation pour se faire
entendre
à écouter c'est difficile on perd à
chaque année quelque chose mais on est
toujours resté dans l'esprit de ce que
l'on n'est pas des gens qui veulent
vivre ensemble oui et qui veulent
protéger le territoire je pense que ça
c'est l'écho qu'on va entendre beaucoup
c c qui malheureusement je veux moi mes
enfants n'ont jamais goûté à du caribou
c'est pas normal ce que dans une
relation millénaire avec des animaux
qu'on a protégé pendant des milliers
d'années en faisant des chasses dépêche
très respectueuse que dans les 500
dernières années la capacité de survivre
ce territoire disparaissent puis combien
de coups des parts dans l'alimentation
qui viennent même position
et puis marine parlait du regard du
monde là tout le monde nous regardaient
vous receviez un appel de la nouvelle
zélande
avez vous des contacts ailleurs dans le
monde comment les gens réagissent qu'est
ce qu'ils disent quand ils voient ce qui
se passe au canada en ce moment cantona
quand je parlais à des amis l'inde au
pays ils sont complètement ils
comprennent pas comme acceptable parce
que tout le monde dans toute la grèce le
monde y pense que la canada c'est un
pays très très ap avec le monde qui tout
le monde rit puis s'est fendu d'un âge
mais c'est pas l'accord mais c'est vrai
comme marine 10 il faut qu'on fasse
quelque chose de suite l'océan
c'est ça bien préparé un petit peu parce
que là il ya beaucoup de monde sur le
sol et je mettrai au pays sont en train
de faire des choses mais c'est une bonne
chose je sais c'est pas combien y en
pour l'allemand mais ça fait 500 années
que c'est pas vraiment combien de temps
mais en même temps il ya des risques
aussi parce que économiquement parlant
ça ébranle un pays on le disait le chaud
dedans ça arrête ça arrête tout il ya
des gens qui risquent de perdre leur
emploi à cause de ça puisque les trains
ne circulent pas la marchandise ne
circulent pas est-ce qu'on va pas finir
par se mettre de plus en plus de monde à
dos au fur et à mesure qu'on avance que
le choc dont deux canadair si on laisse
les choses se faire c'est le chap dans
des territoires c'est le shakedown des
nations c'est comme si on nous
reprochait de nous défendre parce qu'on
nous étouffe ses foules est présentement
l'inconvénient c'est un inconvénient
économique mais l'on parle
d'inconvénients physique on parle parce
qu'on a vu la photo du sniper aucun
guide et on voit vraiment une coercition
forte et physique wii avec des balles
avec des fusils avec des gens qui sont
armés dans le fond de venir sur nos
territoires nous on est assis avec des
tambours et des feux sacrés je pense que
le choc down économique c'est pas un
chat donc des citoyens alors que dans
l'autre sens c'est un choc dans des
citoyens parce qu'il faut penser aussi à
long terme je veux dire ce choc dans là
c'est pour tout le monde comme on le
disait tout à l'heure mais oui
économiquement à court terme peut-être
que ça va brasser des choses mais pensez
aux retombées de l'environnement sur
l'environnement de ce projet là je
visais des chiffres de greenpeace hier
qui disait que dans la première année où
les premières années du de l'oléoduc
donc c'est comme si on introduisait près
d'un million de nouvelles voitures donc
en colombie-britannique donc c'est quand
même pas rien et ça ça vaut doublé au
bout de cinq ans
donc les retombées environnementales
elles sont énormes c'est un projet mais
comme disait mélissa des projets comme
ça il y en a partout au canada
donc il faut penser un petit peu plus
loin que le bout de son nez je pense
juste à la barre
ces machines de cérémonie deep south
bend skin the bass trimestre heart will
go et 2 go back into a respecté à
dancing global voice factory schilb 16
casinos un stop and then minister de
nice people not saying it ministers and
training et louis murat n'dy assembé
affecté retrait de honda obtenait la
cnsa living in fine d'un strapping of
two ways of transportation lyonnais
gaulliste ex actionnaire ou tarp
alors il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
été dites là vraiment intéressante
commençons par expliquer cette
photographie là dont elle parlait alors
il ya une photo il ya des photos qui est
circule présentement ces maisons partout
où on voit justement un agent de la grc
qui sourit avec les robes rouges en
arrière confiante les femmes on voit un
agent de la grc qui prend un tombeau
traditionnels puis qu'ils transportent
de même sans aucun respect alors qu'on
est en pleine cérémonie et on voit que
fouilles de houston qui se fait lire ses
droits pendant qu'elle était en chant
qui se fait emporter qui sont les
enfants qui se fait transporter de force
et sans le respect alors qu'ils auraient
pu attendre la fin de la cérémonie
ça montre est justement le manque de
respect dit ça aurait pu être totalement
différente il avait attendu la vraie et
ça pourrait totalement différent si
aujourd'hui justin trudeau prenait sa
responsabilité qui est la sienne des
relations et des communautés autochtones
il parle avec les chefs pas déléguer à
ses ministres ou pire encore comme on a
vu déléguer au provincial qui n'ont pas
la juridiction sur les affaires liées ou
qu'elle soit indien est allé parler avec
les chefs allait s'asseoir avec eux de
façon respectueuse donc cette escalade
là c'est vraiment fait en collaboration
parce qu'on on entendait justement la
grc qui avait son équipement qui faisait
du bruit pendant la cérémonie
si je peux rajouter au sto qui ont
arrêté les matriarches qui est
impardonnable sur ma ligne
est ce qu'elle disait dans leurs fans
wafa en cérémonie oui tout de suite
après l'image qui accompagne et ceux de
la grc
ce sont ceux de l'industrie qui venait
tout de suite démanteler la barricade
donc on voyait totalement le lien entre
la police au service de l'état pour le
service de l'industrie
et ça ça allait vraiment eu un écho je
pense qui a ébranlé toutes les
communautés autochtones
c'est même plus uniquement à rencontrer
les chefs parce que présentement ils ont
une responsabilité qui en premier avec
les chefs de soweto qui porte un
flambeau incroyable mais il faudrait
quasiment qui arrive dans toutes les
communautés pour expliquer que ça sera
pas quelque chose qui va être faite aux
communautés pour avoir une garantie de
ça malheureusement
ils ont souvent fait des promesses
d'ailleurs marc lynn a rencontré
monsieur trudeau qui lisait notamment
pris et lui a demandé qui ai donné
l'ordre et je pense qu'on aura moi ce
que je vois en réponse à ces kelly a
décidé à c'est pas c'est pas à moi sous
provincial oui avec des femmes
autochtones l'interprétation qu'on en a
fortement au point au point où on en est
rendu aujourd'hui donc ce ne serait pas
au provincial maintenant pour l'instant
de régler la fère ont devancé justin
trudeau qui devrait s'occuper de ce
dossier là c'est gagné lors la bataille
en cours
oui la course il est traité toutes les
attentions avec le fédéral pour le
provincial se fait avec la fédéral mais
je pense que c'est une bon moment pour à
l'apprentissage dans tout ça parce que
ça fait des années qu'on dit on peut
stopper toute l'économie du canada
quand on voudrait c'était les années
quand on dit mais là ça a pris quelque
chose comme ça qui arrive et pour qu'on
le fasse mais on voulait pas le faire
toutes les années avec iphone os mon
blog depuis 1988 avec mon père c'est que
j'ai beaucoup d'expérience et son
confais on égare hier au caire on est
prêt à le faire mais a même chose en
même temps on comprend les économique
puis on veut que on a dû paix puisque ça
va bien parce qu'elle a aimé vous devez
nourrir vos familles vous comprenez les
ans justement c'est comme les saadi on a
beaucoup de familles mixtes et la
personne va partir dit il faut que tu
sais pas ça qu'on dit mais c'est une bon
moment pour voir karl prenois au sérieux
parce que on peut avoir un gros impact
ici c'est pas ça qu'on veut faire mais
s'il faut qu'on fasse on va le faire
mais l'or car le prend sous l'eau il
devrait prendre ça comme une moment
d'apprentissage aller aux tables soir be
ok on a fait quelque chose de pas
correct les choses qu'on fait suite
c'est pas correct mais quand on en
opportunité pour changer ça sinon ça
peut aller très mal
si je peux me permettre parce qu'on dit
beaucoup trudeau présentement et il ya
quelques années je disais harper puis le
j'écoutais d'autres politiciens dans
d'autres partis présentement on nous met
en face un premier ministre qui est
appelé à changer un minimum toutes les
quatre heures au maximum les huit ans
mais c'est de changer la relation avec
le canada car maintenant parce que nous
autres notre relation en tant que nation
autochtone est avec le canada pas avec
les partis politiques
donc c'est c'est même plus grand que
justin trudeau cci grand comme le canada
au complet comme des gens qui
travaillent au ministère comme les gens
qui clique sont des agents de la grc
justement cette relation là elle n'est
pas uniquement dans les mains des partis
politiques qu'elle est dans les mains
des citoyens canadiens
il ya beaucoup de gens présentement qui
ont répondu à la réconciliation j'ai
répondu à la réconciliation parce que
pour moi n'y avait pas d'autre chemin et
je pense que la manière qu'ont fait
encore aujourd'hui encore aujourd'hui
même quand on voit les fusils quand on
voit les les chiens quand on voit toutes
ces utilisations du côté programmation
qui qu'on est encore ici a expliqué à
parler à échanger à vulgariser d'un spa
normal qu'on soit né pour militer on
devrait ni pour exister il continue de
vouloir partager marines et une chef
incroyable elle fait la super bonne
cuisine est impliqué dans la communauté
montréalaise depuis des années oui je
vois partout aux communautés puis on
prévient il les prend sont autant
pouvoir défendre sa communauté à des
milliers de kilomètres donc ça montre
comment on est pris dans ce genre de
politique là même quand on veut aller de
l'avant économiquement qu'on veut aller
de l'avant
culturellement socialement on se
retourne toujours voir des instances
comme celle là qui montre que non on
n'est pas des citoyens comme les autres
et beaucoup de gens comprennent pas
pourquoi
pourquoi est ce qu'ils se font pas
arrêtée aux autres mais si ça
t'intéresse vraiment savoir pourquoi
nous on se fait par et et pourquoi ça
t'intéresse pas de savoir pourquoi on
n'est pas présent dans le canada qu'on
n'est pas actif pour qu'on et demi dans
des réserves
tant qu'on était silencieux et passifs
on était des bons autochtone mais là
maintenant on est des citoyens très
actif puis répliqué par tous pour le
bien être de tout le monde et là ça
dérange contemporain de pointe et des
injustices du pont dit non ça ça marche
pas mais je pense que
y a personne qui va fort dire qu'on a
fait du tort on fait du bien au canada
on ne peut rien lui dire ton cancer peut
le guérir oui qui ça passe par la
réconciliation une vraie réconciliation
alors j'ai consulté je pense que vous
l'avez tous fait les réseaux sociaux au
cours des derniers jours de la dernière
semaine
il ya du meilleur au pire et mais le
pire est présent très présent et quand
les gens pensent aux pires j'imagine
qu'ils se rappellent la crise d'oka par
exemple c'était il ya trente ans ça fait
pas très longtemps 30 ans comment ça va
comment est-ce que ça peut dégénérer
oh mon dieu on peut s'approprier la
lutte des profanations ce qu'on appelle
deux lobes staging c'est à dire dire que
on fait ça pour les ouates souhaitait
mais pas écoutés du tout comment les
chefs ont demandé d'avoir de la pluie de
suivre le protocole des premières
nations de décider de décider de 35 dans
tes propres mains
ça c'est pas respectueux c'est pas une
manière d'être un bon allié faut écouter
les gens avec qui tu veux être allié pas
y aller juste parce que ça brasse puis
que tu vois quelque chose qui bouge mais
il utilisé la bannière des premières
nations
ça je pense que c'est une des choses que
les chefs ont été très clairs à beaucoup
de leurs messages kodak cobac et un
ordinateur en deux sets
un mini bar des sports un tapis de mon
accent est mis à mal
malkin
leader des libéraux chez des amis et
ennemis statut mais venir vous voir des
femmes utilisent comme hugo daknam speak
french may day my one and teaching cobac
wanna go wrong barback
alors on résume rapidement mélissa mais
c'est intéressant parce qu'on a amené le
fameux
wam poma 2 voilà qui a été présenté mais
je vous laisse reprendre ce que nous
disait marlene marlene a expliqué que
justement présentement ça fait depuis
2012 qu'elle est sur le territoire
marocain et qu elle depuis qu'elle fait
cette mobilisation il ya quelques
semaines elle est toujours accompagnée
par le maroc
elle parle avec eux c'est leur
territoire et elle voit comment on va
aller de l'avant avec leur aide parce
que et elle parle aussi avec sa mère qui
est sur son territoire qui lui rappelait
toujours tu vis au québec maintenant on
n'oublie jamais les traditions bien oui
tu viens cependant mme aline suit le
protocole qui dit que c'est qu'on
reconnaît le territoire on reconnaît la
pratique sur le territoire d'une nation
donc oui une chose qui était vraiment
importante puis de marquer on pourrait
ainsi qu'en sur les rails du chemin de
fer ils ont sorti le taureau ou un pont
qui le web comme des rats musqués qui en
ont fait les titres inédits pourraient
saluer un moment d'impact incroyable et
très touchant et justement lié dans la
tradition lit dans cet échange de nation
à nation l'a donc elle vit des moments
très forts aujourd'hui par la solidarité
mais c'est toujours en respect justement
avec les gens qui sont gardiens du
territoire ici donc ça je pense que ça
fait écho à comment on se mobilise en
relation est souhaitée donc on va suivre
le protocole demandé par les oueds
souhaitait d'ailleurs ils y ont des
tours qui est des coffre d'outils pour
les gens qui veulent est en solidarité
avec eux comment les appuis
certaines personnes vont faire des tites
chine ce qui veut dire des ateliers
d'éducation populaire certaines
personnes vont faire des photos des
manifestations ou des sit in des choses
pacifique puis d'autres vont faire des
dons donc présents hier soir mardi
n'était à
au centre d'amitié de lanaudière où ils
ont soupé spaghetti pour amasser des
dons pour leucan une historienne parce
que malheureusement ils vont être pris
dans des décors caisse pour longtemps la
donc pour supporter justement le droit
autochtone c'est en envoyant des sous
oui et lâché que le 22 février ça en
vient aux spectacles à montréal pour
ramasser des fonds pour la nation et wet
souhaitons pour le camp installed
donc ce sont des manières de respecter
le protocole la demande des chefs de
rester pacifiques et de rester à l'image
des oueds souhaité m mais d'appuyer à
distance et ça malheureusement ça va
être sûrement réciproque car ça va être
le cas pour d'autres nations au québec
en ontario un peu partout parce que à
travers cette solidarité là qu'on
réussit à se faire en tant qu'
maintenant on on voit pas ce que malines
et partout dans les médias si d'ici une
de plus en plus c'est difficile aussi de
faire les médias en français et on lui
pose plein de questions mais ces
messages seront pas non plus au québec
dans l'immédiat donc d'avoir des alliés
qui s'assure d'avoir un message
clairement vient de la nation une
sauteuse ou et souhaité m
c'est le cas une hausse totale et la
nation autour de nous il est aussi
extrêmement important donc c'est une
manière d'appuyer justement qui vont
être en respect avec les protocoles
canadie entre autochtone voilà l
émission est déjà terminée ça a passé
tellement vite et d'ailleurs je remercie
marlene d'avoir accepté de venir sur
notre plateau en france est d'avoir pu
vous entendre évidemment nous parler en
anglais mais sur notre plateau tout a
été traduit grâce demander très
rapidement à kwanten est un spectacle
spectacle le 22 février au lion d'or
s'est organisée par le cercle premières
nations du yukon au real oui à ce fait
qu'elle soit là comme youtube sur five
to avec mon band on termine shopi et va
avoir d'autres
[Musique]
j'ai commencé on a fait le même
spectacle et on a commencé 6000 pièces
programmées par là bas c'était et
nombreuses on veut doubler ses talents
si merci vraiment beaucoup à vous tous
on aurait pu encore parlé pendant deux
heures parce qu'ils avaient beaucoup de
jours c'est à dire pour attraper 500 ans
melissa maulin dupuis merci kwanten
condos marly name is about picard merci
à vous quatre et avoue bien sûr merci
d'avoir été là et à la semaine prochaine
au revoir
[Musique]